(hip hop music)
- [Man] Footwork is the body
ganging up with the music.
They both go hand in hand.
(hip hop music)
- [Woman] Footwork, the
energy-packed, high speed
mesmerizing dance born on
the south and west side
of Chicago and the music
that drives the moves.
(hip hop music)
When this movement started in the 90s,
this man was there.
- I am RP Boo and I am
considered the godfather
of Chicago footwork music.
I am a deejay as well as a producer.
- [Woman] The niche moment
has grown worldwide.
- [RP Boo] There are so
many producers in China,
Korea, London.
- [Woman] But it might have
not started if it wasn't
for dancers and deejays who
wanted to speed things up.
(hip hop music)
- [RP Boo] The dance crews was
having a dance competition.
The track that was being
played, it was a normal record.
They were making it go faster.
They actually did a routine to that.
They won this competition.
- [Woman] And when the music
sped up, so did the dance.
- We started off at 145 beats per minute.
I watched it grow from 145 to 160.
The bass building the
footwork track is bass kicks,
snares, drum kicks, hi hats,
plus what sample you gonna
use if you gonna use a sample.
(hip hop music)
The music would sound as close to hip hop
due to the samples.
The groove is something
that's totally new.
That's what separates
it to become footwork.
- [Woman] But without dancers
for the fast paced music,
footwork wouldn't be footwork.
- You go side to side,
front to back,
kick your feets up high and
then whatever move you can do
before your feet hit the floor.
The dance, it sounds simple,
it looks simple
but it does become hard once you try it
if you've never did it before.
- [Woman] As the second
generation is trying to
master the art of footwork,
it's building a positive
global community of dancers
and deejays.
- The impact that the
people in Chicago help
push out to other people
and they saying here,
we love it just as much as you do.
I'm just loving every moment of it.
(hip hop music)